hello and welcome back to spectator tv
into the spectators cop 26 summit i'm
kate andrews the economics editor here
and your host for the next hour as we
discuss the psychology behind going
green this panel is kindly sponsored by
smart energy
so for the next 60 minutes we're going
to focus on what motivates individuals
to be green is it a sense of moral
achievement are they following the crowd
or are they simply trying to save money
now smart energy has worked with the
behavioral architects to study what it
is that turns people into those who
might want to go green and to take real
action on climate change we'll discuss
some of their findings and have a more
general discussion on public opinion
surrounding green action
ia jen mckill is head of public policy
and communications for smart energy uk
bridget williams is the research
director at ipsops mori on social
research institute rory sutherland is
the vice chairman of ogilvy group uk and
they join me now to discuss this
extremely important topic so thanks to
the panel for being here with us on
spectator tv today
each of you are going to give roughly
five minutes of opening remarks and then
we'll move very quickly to questions if
you sitting at home or in the office
would like to submit a question please
do so through spectator tv there should
be a questions box there anything you
submit is funneled directly to me and
i'll put as many questions as i can to
our panel today
rory let's start with you
yes it's a very very interesting problem
um i shouldn't say that because that
sounds as if it's a problem that appeals
to me
for its intrinsic interest rather than
being a problem that urgently needs to
be solved and it is of course both
what makes it interesting is that there
is no absolutely necessary
correlation between the generation of
energy and the production of atmospheric
carbon
there are alternatives there is wind
obviously there's nuclear uh there is a
tidal power geothermal solar power
and at the same time it's worth noting
that there isn't an absolutely direct
correlation between human happiness and
well-being and the consumption of energy
either we don't actually derive any
pleasure from adding carbon to the
atmosphere directly unless you're a
pyromaniac i suppose but most people
don't actually just enjoy setting fire
to hydrocarbons for its own sake they
simply like what energy does for them
now what that means is i think there's
both good news and bad news the good
news is that there are lots of places
you can intervene
in order to reduce carbon emissions both
at the level of energy generation and at
the level of energy consumption and
consumption in general
so in one sense it's a good thing
um the problem is that because there are
many many places you can intervene it's
very easy for this to devolve into what
douglas adams called as someone else's
problem field why should i do this the
problem needs to be solved at the level
of generation or why should i give up
doing this it's really those people over
there who need to give up doing that
there are simple behavioral problems i
mean i grew up in the early 80s when
glue sniffing was a problem i mean it
seems to have gone away i'm not quite
sure why but you basically either had to
stop people selling glue or you had to
stop consumers using it and what you
needed to do was fairly clear
here there's a whole panoply of
different things you cannot actually
adopt in combination which in one way is
good because there's more than one thing
you can do the problem is is that
everybody can easily offload
responsibility onto someone else
and i'm very very pleased that what
we've done here is employ the behavioral
architects to do this research because i
think behavioral economics and
behavioral science has a very important
role to play
in that understanding what it is that
really motivates the behavior you want
to see is really important
and there's a really vital distinction
i'd like to make here which is it
doesn't matter if people do the right
thing for the wrong reasons okay i don't
think we should be in the business of
intentional purity where you say the
only acceptable reason to cut down on
your carbon emissions is basically to
save polar bears and to demonstrate your
altruism if people want to cut down on
carbon emissions to save money
um or they want to do it um simply for
their love of technology or for
aesthetic reasons let's be absolutely
honest most people who bought a tesla
didn't buy it predominantly to save the
environment they bought it because they
thought it was a great car and my view
is that's fine
and so looking at what you can do
to create the behaviors you want to see
and to look at it from a behavioral lens
not necessarily an intentional lens i
think it's a really really important
first step
thanks rory e again
uh thanks kate well yeah i'm i'm yakking
we we're from uh smart eng gb and we're
the the national consumer organization
and you may have seen some of our
adverts
around um smart meters and encouraging
you to adopt a smart meter and adopt uh
the behaviors that come on the back of
that so we've been operating since 2013
to encourage people and to raise
awareness around this major upgrade to
our energy system and we're currently as
an organization overseeing one of the
biggest carbon saving consumer
engagement campaigns of our generation
and so far we've got about 25 million
smart meters installed across great
britain and as i said the smart meter
roll it is a national infrastructure
upgrade and much needed modernization of
a energy system and it ensures that it
is fit for the future
and able to cope with increasing demand
but also make sure that the energy
system is more efficient to help it
reduce carbon emissions
as well as help with the national effort
to tackle climate change and throughout
our campaign since 2013 um we've been
talking about not just smart meters but
also the benefits of what they do to use
for you as a consumer but also what they
can do um for the the climate for
climate change and the environment as
well and at the heart of our campaign
has been consumer insight and research
which helps to inform
our campaign and our messaging
now we primarily communicate
to consumers via mass marketing and
communications activity
but we've also had a very strong focus
on working in partnership with trusted
national local and hyper-local
organizations to make sure that no one
is left behind and that everyone in
society is able to benefit
from smart meters and our experience is
that clear consistent and concise
messaging
informed by in-depth behavioral science
can help turn those individuals good
environmental intentions into tangible
actions now we recently commissioned the
behavioral architects to conduct some
research which upstate updates our
current thinking and understanding of
the drivers of the intention action gap
for energy efficiency behaviors and the
opportunities to minimize that intention
action gap
now that research explores how
behavioral science can help engage
consumers in climate friendly behaviors
and investigates the barriers to
undertaking some of those behaviors it
also assesses why good intentions have
not yet translated into action you know
why do people think it sounds like podi
said
buying a tesla what are the intentions
behind that but some people might think
i would love to get an eb but i'm not
going to do it quite yet so what's
what's stopping them going from thinking
about it to doing and delivering on on
their intentions
and the report also makes
recommendations on how organizations who
communicate with the wider public can
communicate uh with the public around
climate change
uh so our research found that people are
more aware of climate change and the
need to act which is great it's a great
start that people are more conscious of
it it's very much in their minds so i
suppose a large part of the work has
been done it's in in their thinking
great
but the understanding of the science
behind climate change and exactly what
can be done
is still extremely limited
and also things like terminology
is still mostly unknown or not fully
understood so things like carbon
emissions net zero carbon neutral we
talk in a language that the consumers
just don't really understand and that
doesn't help encourage them to move from
intentions to actions because they don't
really know if they're doing the right
thing
and there was also an element of
understanding of the government's
targets is also vague
and to a large degree met with some
skepticism so people were questioning
will we really meet net zero by 2050
there was really kind of questioning if
that was genuine and achievable or was
it just a headline that the government
wanted to put out and we found that over
three quarters of people within the
within the research
um
think it is the responsibility of
government and business to get the
country to net zero so a large part of
society don't really see it as their
role or that they have a role to play
but they think it is government's job or
big business's job to get that net zero
target
and just under half around 44 percent
were unsure of what their individual
actions could be
that would help them to tackle climate
change so there's a big job to do to
educate society around what things that
they can do around their daily lives in
their homes in their workplaces going
about their business that they can do to
help tackle climate change
we also looked at what the motivator
motivators and barriers
were
and what we found very clearly was that
cost saving was the biggest motivator
for people to take action
but we also found there was a minority
of people being motivated by feeling
tech-savvy or green
being part of this
movement around uh helping to fight
climate change but that was to a lesser
degree but there were some people who
who did take climate actions
because it made them feel good they made
it feel part of a growing gang of people
that are out there
but we also look at looked at their
barriers and one of the biggest barriers
was
disposable income and what they were
able to spend money on that achieved net
zero and so as well as disposable income
there was age and property type were
also found to be significant influencers
as to whether people could or were able
to take action
um but being a vulnerable a customer in
vulnerable circumstances was not a
barrier in itself for example being
elderly or living with a disability or a
health condition so we didn't want to we
don't want to kind of make broad
assumptions that somebody who's older or
somebody who was less able to understand
net zero was not able to take part in
the movement towards uh net zero they
are just as able it wasn't a barrier in
itself
so on the back of that we've created a
communications checklist
which
is available on our website smart
energygb.org
and that checklist can be used by any
organization that is able to or looking
to communicate with the public about
climate change and the actions they can
take they can take at home and that
checklist helps you sense check some of
your actions to make sure you're not
using language that they don't
understand or that you're not talking
about things that um the general public
are unable to comprehend um and then
dismiss
taking action because it's just
something that seems too big for them to
do
and it was also very positive just very
finely to see the government
in the last week recognizing the
importance of public awareness and
communication in the recent net zero and
heat and building strategy however
there's a real urgency you know time is
not really on or signed
and this is something which needs to be
addressed really urgently if our efforts
to reach net zero are to be successful
thank you again over to bridgette
thanks very much um a lot of what i'm
going to say times really closely with
what juggins just said
um at ipsos murray we're obviously very
lucky to have a lot of long-term and
frequent data about public perceptions
of climate change we've been tracking it
over many years and i'm sure you won't
be surprised to know we've been quite
busy on it over the last few months
but certainly looking back over the past
few years we've seen issues related to
the environment and climate change
moving up the ranking and it's now seen
as one of the top five most important
issues britain's facing so that's
alongside the economy brexit the nhs and
the kovic pandemic
so we did a poll earlier this month and
in that a quarter of british adults said
without any prompting at all that the
environment was one of the most
important issues facing britain today
one in 10 said it was the single most
important issue and i think there's
become a realization that the
environment isn't now a niche issue it's
linked to the economy and health and
every other part of our lives
and even in the face of the copic
pandemic perception of the environment
is important hasn't waned
so in previous years we've seen numbers
rising and falling quite sharply around
things like extreme weather events but
they have been rising consistently since
mid-2019
uh consent for the environment hit the
highest level ever in august this year
and while we've seen a few wobbles up
and down the direction of travel is
definitely consistent and upwards
i think the other important thing to
mention is when we were looking at this
a few years ago it seemed to be quite a
kind of young metropolitan left-wing
view but now it's become much more
mainstream we're seeing much fewer mark
differences by age or gender or party
support there are still some significant
differences by region and socioeconomic
status but it is much more in the
mainstream
uh we're seeing high levels of worry
about climate change so we had 45
percent of adults telling us in polling
in august that they were worried about
climate change including 19 who were
extremely worried and we do tend to look
at personal worry about climate change
it's a really good predictor of current
and intended future in individual level
behavior change
um there is definite acceptance amongst
the uk public that time horizons are
drawing closer
uh just under seven in ten told us last
month that they think we're already
feeling the effects of climate change
and
a lot of publicity at the same time
we're seeing high levels of awareness of
the target of reaching net zero by 2050
so in august again it was almost 18 10
uk adults were aware of that target
and over half
54 thought the public should achieve net
zero sooner than 2050
so we're seeing high levels of awareness
of climate change and a sense of urgency
we should be doing something about it
but what we're not seeing and again this
kind of goes with what jaeger was saying
is a kind of awareness of the extent of
transformation that's needed in society
for us to hit net zero
so we only had around a third of british
adults in a survey we ran for the global
commons alliance in april recognizing
the need for major societal uh
transformation for us to hit net zero
this was looking across a whole the
whole economy including energy
generation
food production transport and how we
produce and price goods and services
and when we're looking on a more kind of
personal level there's also low levels
of awareness of what the public can do
themselves in the fight against climate
change so we only had 13 in our august
polling saying that they know a lot
about what they personally would need to
reduce uh to do to reduce the uk's
carbon emissions
and i think what we're seeing here is
that over and above a kind of generic
understanding like we need to do
something about transport or
more established things like uh
recycling or reducing waste
there are very low levels of awareness
of the types of changes that need to be
made
the other thing i think is important is
that there's a fundamental lack of
understanding of the carbon saving
impacts of any behaviour change
so we did some polling in april this
year and that showed on average that the
public greatly overestimate the impact
of some of the things they're already
doing like recycling and steering clear
of plastic packaging reusing bags and
things like that and they massively
underestimate the impact of things that
would make a greater difference and some
of these are quite difficult decisions
like
choices on family size or whether you
have a car or whether you have a pet
and these perceptions really haven't
changed much over time so we asked very
similar questions in 2014 nothing's
changed much uh in the time period
so i think taken together
it suggests that there's a need for
transparent feedback to the public on
what needs to be done
when and what the impacts might be so
we're currently seeing a lot of people
on surveys saying that they feel they're
doing all they can to combat climate
change about 56 we saw in a survey just
last month
but qualitative work including
deliberative work through things like
climate assemblies
indicate that a large part of this may
be because they're just not being given
clear consistent and actionable
messaging on what they could and should
do
so just in summary then i think what
we've learned that we think is
worthwhile going forward is that climate
change net zero and the environment are
now named mainstream issues and they're
very topical and they're very salient
we've seen a strong level of public
support for the uk's target of achieving
net zero by 2050 or actually even before
but not very high levels of
understanding of precisely what this
will mean and a need for realistic
conversations about the extent and
nature of transformation that's needed
and we've got a uk public that feels
it's doing its bit or certainly as much
as it's being told to
but who really want further
conversations about the topic and some
clear consistent communications about
the next things we want them to take
thanks so much bridget i have to say i
was really looking forward to this panel
when i saw it was included in our cop26
summit because i think one of the huge
gaps at the moment in this pathway to
net zero and is the government strategy
and its plan and then bringing the
public along which is what we're
focusing on here today and there's so
much to dig into with with all of your
opening comments we're already getting
questions through spectator tv just a
reminder if you're watching from the
officer at home you can submit a
question through spectator tv they're
all funneled to me and i'll try to put
as many to our panel as possible but
given my excitement i am going to abuse
my position as chair and ask a few
questions directly before we get to the
audience questions um rory i'm
fascinated by this idea that you've put
forward before saying that actually
labeling things environmentally friendly
can be counterproductive as people can
often assume it means lower quality what
is the psychology behind that
well i think there's something quite
interesting which is that in some ways
the most passionate environmental
campaigners
are sometimes counterproductive in their
behavior
because what they want to signal and in
some cases of course
their job
is all about environmental campaigning
and if you want to signal your
commitment to a cause
you like to almost
overplay
the degree of self-sacrifice and hair
shirtedness required in order to be
environmentally sustainable simply
because that's how you gain status
points among your immediate committed
peer group
but those behaviors you know rather like
sort of fanatical you know veganism for
example
um
can actually be
discouraging to people who are quite
keen to make some movement at least to
improve things but lack the time money
and resources and status you have to
focus on it to that extent and so we
will tend to assume when we see that
washing powder is kind to the
environment
that it does less of a good job of
cleaning your clothes you know we
mentally assume trade-offs
and i have argued to some manufacturers
of these products that you might be
better doing good by stealth in other
words remove the harmful products but
don't make a lot of noise about it by
the way when we see low fat advertised
on food products we automatically assume
they don't taste as good in fact it's
possible they actually don't taste as
good because of a kind of placebo effect
but
i think there are a few things i'd like
to talk about very quickly
one of which is that they're absolutely
right to mention the intention action
gap they're absolutely right too to
mention the fact that actually we're
being blinded by the headlines because
everybody's trying to get us to do
everything simultaneously and what we're
trying to do is
sometimes trying to save the world one
behavior at a time and sometimes we're
trying to save the world one brand at a
time
and my argument is the way to do this
behaviorally is to save the world one
person at a time
and what we have to do is get experts to
put together a menu of behaviors
almost a point system where you can
choose between these major and minor
behaviors but your aim would be first of
all that poorer people would be set a
lower bar than richer people for the
simple reason that they're doing less
harm to begin with so if i made a
commitment don't fly every other year
okay well 50 of the british population
don't fly in any given year anyway so
they could already tick that box
some behaviors could be very simple put
your washing machine and dishwasher and
tumble dryer on late at night rather
than in the middle of the day when
there's peak demand so some behaviors
can be very easy
but if you could get people to choose
according to their circumstances
a menu of beneficial behaviors
then it would be much much easier for
people to do this rather than telling
everybody they have to do everything at
once it's rather the same with dietary
advice you know one of the great
problems with health advice is it's
effectively keep up you know take up
jogging don't eat fat don't eat salt uh
you know never go to mcdonald's uh well
you know and by the time these various
sort of exhortations have been piled one
on top of the other the natural human
tendency is to say too difficult i can't
do everything so i won't do anything
and i think we could create a menu
approach the second thing that interests
me you're probably already familiar with
nudge theory
but i think there's a kind of
chronological nudge
which i call what you might call a
temporary shove
and i think there's certain behaviors
recycling i think shows evidence of this
that if you force people to do it for a
short time they'll choose to do it in
perpetuity because the adoption of the
behavior
creates effectively a new reality where
you suddenly realize what's good about
the new equilibrium and what was bad
about the old equilibrium
okay a very simple thing if you separate
your um garbage into you know
compost and
recyclables
what you suddenly realize is you have to
worry about the compostables quite
quickly because they start to smell but
actually leaving a whole pile of
cardboard boxes in your
room doesn't really bother you over two
weeks
and so quite often this was true with
multi-channel television
it required a huge amount of persuasion
to get people to shift to it nobody goes
back smart meters very difficult to get
installed once you've got one installed
very few people ask for them to be
removed
and so i think there's also a kind of
what you might call halfway house
libertarianism where you force people to
try something for a short period of time
leave them free to revert to the old
behavior but lee at least on the basis
of knowing what the new behavior is like
and there are tons and tons of behaviors
like this mobile phones i mean someone
shouted abuse at me in 1989 because i
used a mobile phone on oxford street
okay you know social norms change
behaviors change nobody who gets a
mobile phone ever reverts to not having
one or very very few and so i think
there is alongside the nudge approach
and alongside menu design choice
architecture of behavior i also think
there's a role for the temporary shove
but it preserves basic libertarian
principles which is if it doesn't work
for you you don't have to do it in
perpetuity
yank and i was fascinated by bridget's
polling updates that the public often
overestimate certain areas and
underestimate others in terms of how
effective their behavior is when it
comes to combating climate change
although it's not necessarily surprising
that there's certain things that the
public almost don't want to acknowledge
i mean when you are talking about really
difficult things like whether or not you
have a family pet things that are near
and dear to your heart it's almost
easier to overlook that how does the
government the private sector how do we
all go about having an honest
conversation about what's really going
to make a difference here and does it
feed into this
in my opinion a fundamental problem that
where the government wants to go with
its net zero target has not been fully
communicated to the public about what it
might mean along the way
i think it's really important that
people understand that and what their
actions mean uh on the environment and
it was really interesting to hear from
bridget you know that how people uh
under and overestimate their various
behaviors and and i'm probably as guilty
as that uh
as well um i
you know try and use my cars let us
possibly try to take public transport as
often as possible i try and fly as if
it's only essential and there's no other
way of uh of getting there um and i
think i'm i'm you know i'm i'm the best
person to try and save the planet but i
could be wild or wrong there's probably
other things i'm doing in my life that i
think are equally as as good but are
actually not that good
at all so i think there's there is an
issue with regards to communication
to make sure that people understand the
value of actions
um
and also so they they appreciate uh but
also don't they don't devalue their own
actions as well i think there's there's
always uh
an issue with regards to uh
people who quit when they don't
understand or or they don't appreciate
the value of what they're doing so we
often hear people saying so what have i
turned my thermostat down so what if i
wash my clothes at a lower temperature
so what if i recycle so what if i don't
take the car as often i'm not going to
save the planet
and it's also all significantly but you
you will you but you're right you won't
individually
but collectively we will and we all need
to subscribe to this but we all need to
understand the value of our actions and
that value of your action has to be
communicated very clearly very simply
because i think you know as our research
showed with behavioral architects was
you know we use phrases like
carbon neutral net zero energy
efficiency what do these things actually
mean
they're phrases and for a lot of people
that do mean something but they're the
people who are really involved in these
industries day in day out yeah if you're
asking somebody who is just you know man
or woman in the streets who wants to do
their bits
but they're sometimes just baffled by
terminology
so to keep it simple keep it basic but
keep it clear so that people understand
there's a value i suppose it's like as
rory was mentioning you know
you know this menu of actions you know
the if the menu is if you go to a
restaurant you've got a menu of actions
but you've got the cost as well and you
can have the menu of value menu menu of
actions and what the carbon value is or
the net zero value is towards that or
indicatively at the very least it helps
people understand that i can't do that
really
big energy saving thing but i can do
five things up here and collectively
they add to the same value of what that
big thing is so again i think people
just need to see something more visual
clear concise so that they understand
what their what the impact and the
positive impact of their actions will be
one caveat here is things that appear
people have very very little knowledge i
mean even highly educated people have
very little knowledge of what actually
consumes energy
and um they don't understand that
heaters are much worse than televisions
i mean highly intelligent people and so
one thing we've got to be very careful
of is behaviors that have a high
symbolic value but make no difference
because they make i mean i'm very
skeptical about turning off your mobile
phone charger when you're not charging
your phone because in the scheme of
things it's like spitting in the pacific
it's mildly inconvenient and it may
crowd out far more valuable behaviors by
deluding people into thinking they're
doing their bit when really they're
making no difference at all
bridget we've been talking broadly about
people who would like to do more to
tackle climate change in their own
behavior but perhaps don't know exactly
how to go about it but what about
engaging with the sizable minority there
are some estimates that it's even one in
four people who simply aren't motivated
to tackle climate change
i think there's lots of ways to do it it
doesn't always have to be positive about
climate change
there are many other benefits to making
net zero positive behaviour changes
which
could be motivating to them and if we're
doing it kind of by stealth
and sort of around the corner then then
that's absolutely fine um we did some
sort of quite interesting work through
the pandemic
where we asked people about the
behaviors that they had changed through
the pandemic and much of it was because
of lockdowns you know they couldn't
travel as much they were doing more
local journeys on foot rather than
taking public transport or cars
um they were separating food waste more
at home just because they were at home
more
um so we asked them about a big range of
different things and you know i mean you
don't want to say that good things come
out of the pandemic but a lot of people
did change their home behaviors a fairly
micro level
uh through that period and a lot of them
actually intended to carry on as they
came out of the pandemic but when we
asked them about their reasons for doing
it the main motivations were money
so it was saving them money at a time of
sort of financial instability it's
because it improved their well-being or
the well-being of their family
uh then it was because of the lockdowns
and then it was because of climate
change
so i think that you know if we were just
asking people to make these changes
their behavior because of climate change
you are going to come up with certain
barriers and then there are other
conversations happening about the
balance of individual level behavior
change versus tech change and how that's
going to get us to net zero it all
becomes very complicated
but people do really understand it's
going to save you money and it's going
to be better for your health and the
health and well-being of your family
so if people are doing it for that
reason but we still have the same net
benefit i don't think there's anything
wrong with that
i can't absolutely budget we you know
behavioral architects research the top
two uh first of all saving money that
was the biggest motivator and the second
was protecting the next generation which
ties in with protecting your family
protecting your kids your grandkids
everybody around you so again there's
there's
the motivators that people want people
to react to aren't necessarily what
people actually react to and i think
that's where we need to listen to what
the public wants
rather than voice something on them say
oh it's just you have to be green you
have to be tech savvy you have to be
this actually just give the messages
give the motivators that will actually
create the climate-friendly behaviors
i've heard people say oh it's it's
really sad when somebody is more
motivated about saving money rather than
saving the planet
but my thinking similar to budget is if
the cost motivate motivator is what gets
them to save the planet so be it it we
still end up with the same result
but we shouldn't all be kind of moral
high ground about it
we also we also have in mind that's good
we also have a point that behavior
changes attitude it doesn't only work in
one direction
and if you get someone to adopt a
pro-environmental behavior for the wrong
reason
they will generally become
environmentally better disposed as a
result of behaving that way
and that's actually on page 11 of the
report and it's a very useful insight
that quite often the initial spur is
cost saving
but then the
performance of the action
causes them to appreciate the
environmental contribution they're
making for it and therefore continue
performing the action so sometimes you
get someone over the line through cost
saving but what actually maintains the
continuance of the behavior is the
environmental consciousness
having bought an electric car i am now
much more smug and more likely to
lecture owners of petrol cars
than i was three weeks ago
um
sorry just kind of linked to this is
also kind of changing people's defaults
a little bit
to sort of help them to get to that
place so for example you know there's
been a big kind of change to use of
renewables in energy
and
you know the public
didn't drive that particularly there may
have been some attitudinal drivers in
support for that policy
but you know they haven't seen any great
changes and people who are moving on to
green tariffs which also in some cases
have cost saving and well-being saving
kind of
impacts feel good about it so i think as
well as encouraging people to change
their behavior by itself there's also
about changes to policy and what's
happening under underlying that which
enable people to carry on doing the
things that they were kind of doing
anyway
but also sort of reaping these
environmental benefits
again you uh well to rory's point there
he says he's rather smug now that he has
his evie and you could blame him and one
of the findings um in smart energy's
report is that the desire to be seen as
tech savvy can actually be a very good
motivator for some customers when it
comes to going green is that going to
work with things like heat pumps though
i mean they're important not the sexiest
topic it doesn't necessarily make you
feel as boastful as perhaps rory is with
his ev
actually i i do find heat pumps slightly
sexy so i'll just come back to you on
that rory i'd love it okay yeah i
appreciate that's a nice i appreciate
that's a niche opinion
actually the heat pump's very very
interesting because like all remarkable
technologies it's got an element of
magic to it and even i and i write on
technology for the spectator
i can't quite get my head around the
fact that actually it produces five
times as much heat as the energy that it
costs to run
because when my outdoors is cold
it seems completely counterintuitive to
me that you can extract heat from an
exterior that is colder than your
indoors now of course the way it works
if you look at temperature in degrees
kelvin
you realize there's still quite a lot of
heat energy in a frozen lawn but it
takes a hell of a lot of mental
gymnastics to get over that hurdle i
have to admit
are you as convinced that um all of your
customers will be as excited about heat
pumps as rory i watch youtube videos
about heat pumps
i'm loving my science lesson here this
is this is probably more than i ever
learned in school so um yeah it's a
tricky one because i think being tech
savvy is a small proportion of of
society
and i think with with something like net
zero it has to apply to everyone so we
don't want to focus too much on on the
tech side of things because
first of all not everybody can afford it
uh but not everybody wants to adopt it
and employ because they're just not
comfortable using it so we have to
appreciate that there are sections of
society where tech is absolutely
brilliant and whether that's you know
the latest apps and controls on your
phone to manage your heat and your
appliances in the home uh via your smart
meter or whether it's something like
decarbonizing heat in your home with a
heat pump whether it's ground or air
so there's
it's kind of horses for courses really
um i think for us as an organization we
have to communicate with
the entirety of great britain and that
covers all social circumstances
so you know i'm i would say like i'm not
not a rory i'll be honest i'm but i'm
not at the other scale i'm probably in
the mid-range of
of of techiness and i'm comfortable with
that um
but i don't want uh something like the
smart meter roll it and the evolution of
energy tech to be seen as exclusive to
be seen for those who are
always at the cutting edge of technology
because you then start to lose the
people who can't afford it who who
aren't comfortable with it but sometimes
those who can't afford it are those who
need to save the most money because of
their individual circumstances so tech
is important things like heat pumps
we're talking about hydrogen for heat
coming down the line at some point
possibly and all these things but we
can't afford to talk too much about it
and be too obsessed with it because
there are some sectors of society who
just need extra support to be convinced
that some of this some of this
evolutionary technology is beneficial
and some of it doesn't actually cost
that much money at all
bridget you've been involved with
several government schemes intended to
get people to insulate their homes or
improve their energy efficiency what
were the lessons from that
um well firstly like rory i'm i get very
excited uh about energy efficiency and
watch youtube videos about people
insulating their home so you know it's a
it's amazing what to press these
different people's buttons
at the moment
um i think that um
some of the sort of main learnings are
about kind of educating people as to the
benefits of it um i think that people
still think that there's a lot of hassle
involved and that that hassle isn't
worthwhile you know even to the point of
people telling us that they're not going
to get free insulation put in their loft
because they can't be bothered to take
all the boxes out
um so that somebody can go in and put
the insulation in and i don't think it's
about
kind of not being bothered but i think
it's about that trade-off between the
immediate hassle and the longer term
sort of savings
certainly with the energy crisis um
that's happening at the moment we've
seen quite a few energy supplies going
out of business there are less kind of
um
cost beneficial tariffs available and
i'm saying we're seeing a lot more in
our kind of monitoring that we're doing
of people now actively looking for ways
that they can save on their energy bills
because they can't now look at kind of
switching as a way to save money
and these conversations are coming up
again but it's about making that access
easy making sure that the um
the sort of economic operations are in
place so that people can access things
quickly there aren't big sort of
surprises or supply chain issues when
there are surges in demand for example
um and i don't think that people really
understand all of the little things that
they can do
um to save energy in their home as well
through insulation or improving the the
efficiency of the heating that they have
i think finally and it kind of also
relates to electric vehicles and smart
meters and everything and
for a lot of the newer technologies that
are coming in there aren't a lot of um
kind of examples and or reasons to
believe so there's not a lot of talk out
there of people who look like me in
areas
like mine who live in houses that look
like mine that having good experiences
of heat pumps for example
um so i think there just need to be some
kind of reasons to believe so that
people feel that this might be an option
for them
and also to bring the prices down that's
the other cool thing because they're
quite expensive at the moment i'll give
you an example with smart meters about
how you might sell them the great
benefit you discover when you have a
smart meter is nothing to do with the
environment it's the fact that before
you leave the house put it in the
hallway before you leave the house you
can check you haven't left anything
switched on now that doesn't just reduce
waste it also reduces your paranoia
about how something's going to catch
fire as soon as you knock your front
door
before
so so actually
fear of your home burning down is more
salient than fear of unwanted carbon
emissions so why not use it you know in
persuading people to adopt that
technology so
we have some questions filtering in from
the audience and ia jen i'll go to you
first um
and i think this this actually really
sums up a lot of what we've been talking
about here
um don't you think the green eco option
is not always the most economic option
eg electric cars and heat pumps now as
passionate as our panel seems to be
about evs and heat pumps let's be honest
even with that five thousand pound
subsidy that the government's announced
for 90 000 households to upgrade their
boiler that is it's simply this is
technology that is simply not affordable
to a lot of people right now so we can
talk about the benefits that exist
within tackling climate change and also
for the consumer but if you can't afford
it agent you can't afford it
that is that is yeah it's been an issue
i think it's been an issue for a long
time and it's not something that's
that's all of a sudden appeared because
you know electric vehicles have
typically been more expensive than a
petrol or diesel-powered car so those
that those affordability issues have
always been around and i think they're
becoming more obvious now that
things like electric vehicles heat pumps
different heating systems are more in
people's consciousness
so people understand a bit more of them
but are immediately or very quickly put
off the idea because of the
affordability
and you can talk until you're blue in
the face to say but in the long term
you'll recoup your costs because your
heating costs go down and your energy
costs go down likewise with the electric
vehicle you're not paying for uh petrol
and diesel which at the moment we know
is like other fuels very very expensive
but for many people they're living in
the here and now they're not living in
five or ten years time they're living in
the here and now and they need to buy
things now they need to whether it's
stuff or in the their home or their
children or their wider family they they
don't have
25 30 000 pounds for
heat pumps or for new heating systems or
for
electric vehicles so that is a barrier
and that's that's what certainly what we
found in our research was disposable
income
was a barrier to people
making that leap so the intention is
there they love the idea
but the
ability to do it financially
was quite a stumbling block for them and
and that is where you know we need
whether it's government coming in to try
and remove some of those barriers or or
will it be something that the market
will eventually thrive you know we look
back at the days of of the video
recorders and uh you know rory with his
with his brick mobile phone walking down
oxford street which for a lot of people
those points were weird of a reach
yeah but now they're very very
ubiquitous
the problem is i don't think time is on
our side for that to happen
so
you know if we want to get
heat decarbonized and transport
decarbonized we can't wait for the
market to drive it so that people can
afford it that that really needs to
happen quite quickly so that people can
adopt the technologies that will allow
them to decrease their heat and
transport but they need to do it quite
soon rather than wait further down the
line because that might just be too late
for us
and rory on that point and you know it's
very optimistic and has been proven
right time and time again that the
market will continue
um to advance and to innovate and the
cost of all this technology will go down
but in the here and now
and as ej mentions for the foreseeable
future
it it just may not be a possibility
um just be a bit careful i mean
obviously you can't do everything
overnight i mean it's worth noting on
the electric car thing yes it's a rich
person's niche
but it's also worth noting that it's
always only been a tiny minority of the
population who buys cars from new okay
and these things are new we don't really
have a fully developed secondhand market
for example
it hasn't yet permeated the rental
market but it will
my contention is that actually most
people who've experienced an electric
car don't go back
and so it's not one of these behaviors
where you have to continually work at it
it's much closer to the mobile phone
where once driven forever smitten to
borrow an advertising line from vauxhall
15 years ago i think okay that generally
the experience of the thing creates its
own converts in this case and i accept
the fact that it's a rich person's thing
equally rich what do you want me to buy
again do you want me to buy a louis
vuitton steamer trunk instead you know
okay i have got the money most
technology starts with rich it is worth
noting that technophiles can be just as
off-putting to the mass population as
absolutely fanatical environmental
campaigners can be
that people on the extremes
um often actually slightly
unintentionally stigmatize the behaviors
they adopt so it's something we've just
got to be a little alert to and i think
understanding how the what you might
call the early majority and the
followers uh will actually be persuaded
to adopt this technology is not the same
task as selling it to the first 10
percent
richard i'd be interested in the polling
and the feedback on this do the public
often feel like tackling climate change
and is a rich person's gain as if you
know they're actually not included in
that process or is it a bit more
positive do people feel like their small
changes are really having an impact
i think there is a view that small
changes are impacting and i think
everybody wants to feel that they're
contributing so you know i'm i'm very
glad that that's the case because if
people were feeling i don't think there
is a strong feeling that it's somebody
else's problem now with it moving much
more into the mainstream
i think the other thing that's kind of
quite interesting is
the
positivity about this and positivity
that you can make a difference also
helps to drive behavior um and i'm you
know there's been quite a lot of sort of
negative messaging and a lot of doom and
gloom in a lot of the things that we're
talking about and clearly that's needed
to get people to take notice to start
with but i think that there is
definitely a balance to be struck
between
it's so terrible i can't do anything
about it and the little things that i'm
doing can at least help me to start so
i'm just looking on this screen we did
some polling in 2019
i'm looking at that we had 62
thinking that if they had hoped that
they could reduce climate change they
would be more likely to do more about it
so i think that we do need to tell
people that there is hope
that they personally can make a
difference even through the little
things and build up from that so
whatever your financial circumstances
whatever your family circumstances
and whatever lifestyle you're leading at
the moment there are things that you can
do to contribute and taken together we
can all contribute together
we have a reminder very quickly to um
those watching uh from the office and at
home at your last opportunity to submit
questions through the question box on
spectator tv they're funneled directly
to me we have a few more to get through
that i already have but last opportunity
to submit rory over to you
we have a rather nice case study in the
last two years of the efficacy of the
temporary collective simultaneous shove
which is the adoption of video
conferencing
which i uh ey large consulting firm has
banned all business travel for trips of
one night or less all flights okay that
would have been impossible three years
ago because the norms were different
and i think we would have adopted this
technology otherwise but it would have
taken 10 or 15 years to do so
and so that's an example where actually
suddenly enforcing a behavior for a
short period of time can prove
remarkably sticky in the longer term
um we have another question through from
jim clark about language
he is mentioning frank lunds here who is
the american pollster who often does the
focus groups after before and after a
presidential or or primary debate in the
states he's been spending some time in
the uk at the center for policy studies
and he has recently given the advice
that we should stop talking about green
and instead just focus on the benefits
safer cleaner as opposed to greener the
panel's thoughts rory start with you
someone wrote to me making exactly this
point um ironically they wrote to me
from an oil rig in the south china seas
but there we go and they made the point
that actually certain
messages
for example carbon isn't something that
particularly motivates us it's invisible
odorless and we don't perceive it in any
shape or form whereas cleaner air or for
example things like rewilding
may appeal to people because they
actually convey a benefit
and so i completely agree that i don't
think we've got the language right in
lots and lots of ways i mean carbon
neutral is actually if you think about
it a slightly unambitious frame we
should be looking for activities to be
carbon positive as well and so
neutrality
once you've used the word carbon neutral
you have without even being aware of it
you've set yourself a slightly too low
bar in many cases
again
absolutely i think language is super
important in in all of this um you know
certainly in our work with regards to
the smart meter rollout you know we have
to take something that's quite technical
to but distill it down to the point
where people can understand and
understand the benefits um
around the the benefits of adopting the
technology but equally we you know we're
probably guilty in some of the language
that you know but we need that language
to evolve so it is becoming more
simplified and understandable and
relatable um so certainly the behavior
change report behavior architecture
report that we did
as i mentioned earlier carbon emissions
net zero carbon neutral didn't resonate
with them because people couldn't
visualize what does that mean
but it needs to be a
shift to the language of of being more
positive more relatable and you know to
to bridges point around you know the
language has to be positive as well and
people understanding that their actions
are making positive changes
sometimes we're presented with an
armageddon kind of doomsday scenario in
some of the discussions around climate
change
and then people think well it's is it
too late uh or again will my little
actions make any difference at all so
why should i bother because it sounds as
if it's game over but it's changing that
language to being a bit more
inspirational a bit more motivational
and really encouraging people to
understand and never devalue their
actions as little as they think they
might be but never devalue them but it
is really really changing that that
narrative around to being uplifting
inspiring rather than doomsday
bridget i think there's there's a really
great example the earth shot prize that
was on well he's been running for about
nine months it was on tv last week
and that has purposefully taken a very
kind of positive
uh less kind of doom and gloom approach
and i think that that's a really good
way to move in the future it also
focuses a lot on some of the benefits of
um reducing
um sort of carbon emissions and taking
climate action on things like protecting
and restoring nature and improving
people's lived environments and i think
i definitely agree talking about the
benefits to an individual and to their
lives as a whole um is a really positive
step to take
we have a few minutes left and one of
the questions that's come through
reads
the government uh is focused so much on
the policy and not enough on the
psychology what are the easy wins here e
again let's start with you
um
how long ago are there no easy wins is
that the reason we're not so focused on
psychology well i think i think i think
the psychology is becoming more and more
part of it which is really really
encouraging
um you know what you know what bridget
was
was saying there you know that's
exactly you know the way people are
thinking and how they react to things
rory's experience uh of of engaging and
messaging and hours with regards to to
the to the smart meter role there's
there's lots of information out there as
to what sort of stimulates what
motivates uh individuals to do something
and not just do it as a one-off but do
it as a learned behavior or
a behavior change whether it is that
thing that pushes you down a certain way
but then becomes the norm for your life
um you know obviously policy is
important because it gives us the
direction of travel and it gives us the
intention by the policy makers in the
government
but i think
a deeper understanding of what what
makes a consumer tick
and not ever not and we're not
homogenous we all have different things
that tick our boxes so again
understanding what works for one section
of society and you know what works for
me you know even today rory is super
excited about his heat pump um i i might
be a late adopter to that that's
probably given the type of property i'm
in um but there's different things that
take people's different people's boxes
and and that's what i think the
psychology of the whole
messaging around um
the
the the environmental and and the the
journey towards net zero is super
important
by understanding what makes people take
will really help the government
communicate that message
and make sure that the messages stood
understood across society rather than
just for the energy savvy or the tech
savvy because
you know they're probably ahead of the
game anyway it's the people who don't
understand or who need to understand
what role they can play
in in all of this is but that language
has to be simple but it has to be
appropriate and relatable to that
particular group as well but that's
where the psychology and understanding
you know again what makes that consumer
tick
rory one of the criticisms of the
government so far is that it hasn't
really been thinking about the consumer
and we've actually seen in recent weeks
boris johnson pivots slightly
acknowledging more that there have been
concerns about the cost of all this what
it will actually mean for your
day-to-day life and now the prime
minister is insisting that this isn't
going to come in through force you're
not going to be told you have to rip out
your gas boiler you're not going to be
told that you can no longer buy meat
products
the government's going to take a slowly
slowly approach to winning the public
over so again are there are there easy
solutions to that negotiation finding
that sweet spot or is the problem that
the government has just put policy so
far forward of the psychology perhaps if
it had done this in reverse the public
would already be ready and willing to
sign up to some more of these difficult
times one of the problems one of the
problems with government is that it is a
government okay i'm very proud of that
can it i'm a very big fan of um a book
by james c scott called seeing like a
state
which is and he's an anarchist
anthropologist but strangely writes a
book which is almost a defense of
conservation conservatism very strange
book
but the tendency to see things in
average terms
and also the tendency to do legislation
first economic second and persuasion
third
strikes me as a fundamental mistake i'm
not suggesting for a second even as an
advertising executive that this entire
problem can be solved in purely through
voluntary individual action
but i think we should look at what what
progress we can make voluntarily first
bring in economic incentives second
where those fail and then only resort to
compulsion as a last resort
now of course government consists of a
lot of lawyers who occasionally take
advice from economists and never talk to
advertising executives and so they tend
to approach everything from the opposite
direction now i'm not saying my
direction's right i'm simply saying
there's an inherent bias in the way that
a legalistic authority looking at
essentially the average representative
consumer there's a limit to how many
problems they can solve
because the number of problems you can
solve by imposing the same rules on
everybody regardless of their individual
circumstances whether it be financial or
the house they live in i'll give you an
example okay caroline lucas head of the
green party flies to new york once a
year okay
she gets a lot of flack for that her son
lives in new york what's she expected to
do not see her son it's ridiculous okay
everybody has different circumstances
and the great thing about persuasion
is if you've got a good reason you can
ignore it and do something else instead
the problem with legislation is it's a
very very blunt implement
and so there is a lot you can achieve
through voluntary action which is
impossible to achieve through forced
coercion or imposition at least in the
kind of state which we wish to inhabit
which is not completely totalitarian
bridgette one of the lessons that some
people are pushing around the kova
crisis is that it turns out surprisingly
if you tell the public to do something
they will comply but that does seem to
be breaking down when it comes to the
green agenda there doesn't seem to be
this confidence that as rory says if you
just try to force us on people or
legislate that it will necessarily go so
well
do you get the sense from your polling
that voluntary measures are going to be
more popular on this pathway than those
that are legally binding
um i think that carrots always go down
better than sticks and um encouraging
people to come along with you will
always have a better
outcome than enforcing things on them
that's just kind of human nature
um and we found that in polling as well
we asked people who had changed their
behavior what would encourage them to
continue with those sort of positive
behavior changes that they'd made and it
was about things like incentives and
putting the infrastructure in place to
make it easy for them to carry on doing
that
and and i think that for any behavior
change it's very much about um kind of
the policy and the psychology working
together so using the psychology and
policy design but also optimizing the
policy to work with the humans um within
it and that's just the basics of of how
things really should work
um behind the scenes i've got a can i
read a nice little quote from a lady who
i spoke to about this
um
she said uh what everyone's learned this
is from the pandemic is how the
impossible can be possible and how
adaptable people can be
it's really shown that we can make
drastic changes to our lives if we have
to or if we're told to and i think
that's encouraging
before the government might have shied
away from policies they thought people
would refuse because they possibly would
not go in their cars or they wouldn't
possibly not fly but it's shown that
people can and will and they should
learn and take heart from that
definitely
well i'm very sorry to say that we are
out of time because this has been a
fascinating discussion i want to thank
eagan bridget and rory for joining me
here on spectator tv a big thanks to
smart energy for making this panel
possible and a huge thank you to those
in the office and at home who have
decided to join us and for submitting
your question i'd encourage you to head
back over to spectator tv click on the
next link and watch our final panel tips
for living green for now thank you and
have a great afternoon